what's up guys Ryan right here there's a
few videos that drop recently that I got
in a few requests for them and I expect
more to come in but I wanted to start
off with Jack Nicholson reacts to the
new Joker I I hope it's one of those
like funny put together slice reaction
videos but here we go let's check this
[ __ ] out about Schmidt
this is gonna be good
yes that's what happened and that's see
that was good that was good
I like these slice together stuff I mean
this is gonna be more popular as Matthew
McConaughey Jack Nicholson I think there
was another one these things are gonna
be coming out like crazy it's crazy what
this reactor world has become you know
and I started doing reactions it was
just because people wanted them like I
just did it were fun the first like two
times then suddenly people end up loving
them so I'll just keep doing more and
then now there's like so many [ __ ]
people there's a time where were just
like the finebros and gator martin but I
think these solo reactors are you know
they're different than the finds we're
coming after you find brothers the
reactors will assemble and take down you
guys or we'll all just become big
youtubers and eventually go on youtubers
you react but know this kind of stuff
I'm gonna see we're gonna see so many of
them and I hope myself to put together
one of these because these are so fun
they're great parodies of what like
these reaction videos tend to be like I
really do enjoy these and I'll keep
watching them up it's taking a
celebrity's clip and then putting a
trailer or something over it for a
reaction it's really funny stuff anyway
guys thank you so much for mentioning
that was out if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter I'm trying to get
product placement from breast
enhancement surgery places so if I get a
certain amount of followers I can
approach them and then talk about
getting breast enhancement for women who
desperately need it I can think of a few
but I'm not gonna save their names Keira
Knightley kidding Kira's beautiful I
used to want to put my penis in her sec
cui Baha I think I found someone just as
weird as you he goes to my school
weirder jokes hobbies same hair that's
cool man I want to meet this guy and
then murder him cuz there could only be
one Highlander I don't like hearing that
there's people like me no I want to be
one of a kind so my friend I want you to
assassinate this friend to murder him
slice open his throat pull out his vocal
cords and
and send them to his mother if you
listen to these instructions a you're
crazy for listening to me be I'm proud
of you